boris johnson ist bei uns der britische
premierminister
so ist die welt nach diesem g7-gipfel
eine bessere eine sicherere
als die welt
nach dem gipfel das haben sie gesagt
also
man kann es so formulieren als wir nach
schloss elmau haben gab es sehr viele
medien die gesagt haben er kann
deutschland das überhaupt so einen
geeinten gipfel auf die reihe bekommen
mit deutlichen botschaften über die
ukraine oder irgendwas anderes und
tatsächlich waren es hervorragende zwei
tage weil man wirklich zusammengewachsen
ist und die logik ist einfach natürlich
wollen alle dass der krieg zu ende geht
ganz verzweifelt wenn man das aber es
gibt keinen möglichen deal putin macht
keine angebot eines deals senske kann
auch kein angebot machen
die logik ist dass wir jetzt
und darauf hatte auch noch geeinigt was
wir jetzt versuchen das ein zielinsky zu
helfen die dynamik umzudrehen
die position umzudrehen er ist und die
ukraine hat ja gezeigt dass sie ein
gegenangriff auf die beine stellen
können sehr effektiv sie haben die
russen hinaus claire vertrieben sie
haben sie damals kg vertrieben
das ist eine hervorragende
wirklich hervorragendes geleistet und
wir haben das über
die humanitäre und wirtschaftliche und
das wird so ein kinderhaus
und deutschland und der g 7 gipfel
insgesamt haben wir 30 milliarden dollar
wirtschaftliche humanitäre hilfe
zugesagt für die ukraine das ist ein
großer betrag aber
die länder kommen jetzt auch zusammen
oben der ukraine zu helfen bei der
militärische strategie aber prime
minister ich glaube was viele viele
menschen in deutschland und sicherlich
auch in großbritannien umtreibt ist die
frage wie lange wird es dauern es gibt
ja sehr sehr viele tote es gibt viele
befürchtungen auf die folgen des krieges
was energiepreise angeht zum beispiel
haben sie ein enddatum können sie uns
ein enddatum nennen
ja natürlich gibt es eine ukraine
müdigkeit da verstehe ich schon mal bora
ziehen aus wollen
einfach wird das nicht das kann ich
nicht so
was sehr beeindruckend waren anhand
hätten gespräche geführt haben ist dass
die menschen dass wir jetzt den
ukrainern eine strategische
durchhaltevermögen geben wollen und alle
sind sich einig
der ukrainischen regierung und man kann
ja nicht um ukrainischer werde als die
ukraine die ukraine muss entscheidend
aber man will sie helfen einer besseren
verhandlungsposition zu sein wenn es
dann zu gesprächen kommen und das ist
die strategie zu sein und gleichzeitig
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass wir bereit
sind der ukraine die sicherung
zusicherungen zu machen die die ukraine
braucht für die zukunft weist die
lieferung mit nato guten nato material
betrifft die ausbildung und
nachrichtendienstlich unterstützung dass
man die eu kann nicht wieder angreifen
kann jetzt hat man herr premierminister
allerdings von ihnen ja auch noch eine
andere seite gesehen bei dem g7 gipfel
sie haben gleich ganz am anfang ein
bisschen gemacht haben gesagt wir
sollten
jackett ausziehen und wladimir putin
unsere muskeln zeigen ist das ihre art
mit putin umzugehen ihre strategien
vielleicht auch ein bisschen lächerlich
zu machen ihn zu demaskieren
also ich habe ja
einen anderen beitrag doch gemacht
kerstan in der debatte über
nahrungsmittelsicherheit und
geschlechtergleichheit und da war ich
ganz ernst und habe gesagt
wichtigsten ostbahn braucht ist 12 jahre
hervorragende bildung auch jedes mädchen
auf der welt für jedes menschen auf der
welt die gleiche bildung bekäme wie die
jungs dann wird das hervorragend für die
menschheit hervorragend für den planeten
und man braucht einfach mehr frauen in
positionen der macht wenn putin eine
frau wäre
also wenn das wäre dann
diesen verrückten macziol krieg diese
invasion licht vom zaun gebrochen wenn
man ein perfektes beispiel für toxische
männlichkeit dann ist es das was er
gerade in der ukraine gemacht sie haben
gesagt dass das meeting dass das sammelt
hier der gipfel hat viel gebracht nach
zweieinhalb tagen mit ihren kollegen
hier spüren sie wie gut es sein kann in
einer starken union zusammen zu arbeiten
natürlich ist es gut und wir haben ja
sehr viele solche gemeinschaften wir
haben uns gerade hier getroffen als der
67 wir uns wieder als nato
ja ich weiß
das ist immer sehr viele meinungen zum
wechsel geben wird und ich dachte schon
mal sagen je schneller das in den
hintergrund gerät
und wir diesen punkt hinter uns lassen
er ist es besser es ist denn ich bin der
auffassung dass die stimmung sich jetzt
wirklich dreht zum positiven
ich glaube das argument ist jetzt
einfach durch es hat lange gedauert aber
wir haben jetzt abgeschlossen und ich
möchte alle unsere zuschauer in
deutschland sagen dass es nicht heißt
dass uk deutschland nicht liebt oder die
eu nicht liebt oder nicht er hat enge
beziehung haben möchte das möchten wir
wirklich sehr gerne
es gab einige dinge die die britische
öffentlichkeit nicht mehr haben wollte
und meinen job für ist es das wirklich
oben zu setzen und dafür zu sorgen dass
wir dann sehr tief greifendes
verständnis füreinander haben über
unsere werte über das was uns
zusammenhält freihandel demokratie
menschenrechte das aufstehen für das
anders wir glauben auf der welt
rechtsstaat dass prinzipien bei dass man
ländern nicht überfallen sollte so viel
es geht es zu tun und dass viele
britinnen und briten der meinung sind
sie wären wirtschaftlich besser dran
wenn sie in der eu wären das stört sie
nicht dass
die diskussion habe geführt die welt es
gab eine abstimmung
und die menschen haben sich dagegen
entschieden ich möchte
ich möchte hier nicht irgendwelche die
ist
das polemische bemerkungen machen über
vorteile oder nachteile der europäischen
union es hatte alles schon gemacht das
ist durch jetzt wo es das vereinigte
königreich
sich weiterentwickeln und das könnte
sein das ist auch vorteilhaft ist für
die europäische union es kann ja sein
dass wir die dinge anders anpacken als
die europäische union bei manchen
verordnungen bei daten oder gehen
bei banken usw haben wir einen anderen
ansatz und das brüssel vielleicht auch
so schlecht ist die idee überhaupt nicht
die briten da haben und dann bekommt man
eine gegenseitige befruchtung ein
wettbewerb zwischen uns sie haben ihre
unterstützung hierfür die ukraine im
kampf gegen russland verglichen mit dem
kampf gegen adolf hitler ist das für sie
wirklich eine vergleichbarkeit
ich denke
ich wollte da darauf hinaus
dass die demokratie
und tyrannen sich unterscheiden und in
der geschichte da war es aber eine zeit
bis die demokratien
fassen die energie finden zu reagieren
auf den ball ein tyrann ein keine
schneller agieren weil sie keine
demokratischen und
kontrollmechanismen haben aber was
passiert ist auf der welt wenn man das
schaut was so passiert dann sieht man es
gibt klare vorteile das hatte der
demokratin ich glaube nicht dass das in
einen so großen fehler gemacht hätte
wenn es sich um eine demokratische
regierung gehandelt hätte hätte leute
gehabt die gesagt hätten das geht so
nicht
die demokratien verlieren vielleicht die
erste hälfte des fußballspiels oder
vielleicht soll ich das beispiel nicht
mehr mit deutschland weil wir die brands
gewinnen gegen deutschland aber
ich vielleicht anders formulieren die
demokratien brauche zeit bis sie
wirklich handeln können bei einem großen
problem aber dann wird es gelöst zb
corona
angefangen hat es
dass die chinesen richtigen einsatz dazu
haben wir denn ein locker zu machen aber
jetzt am schluss war es ganz klar dass
die großen demokratien der welt die g7
länder haben mit diesem effektiven
impfstoffe entwickelt habe
und jetzt ist es so dass wir den
lockdown abgebaut haben weisen die die
chinesen nicht herum noch ein anderes
beispiel möchte ich sagen
waschen zum beispiel wieso angeblich
hoch gelobte militärische und maschine
der großen das hat sich doch gezeigt
dass die maschine noch nicht so gut ist
dass die raketen doch teilweise
rohrkrepierer sind in die defekte wollen
nicht so effektiv sind auch dem start
wie manche gedacht haben
ich will also sagen das ist demokratie
möglicherweise langsam sind das
demokratische prozesse vielleicht
schmerzhaft sind aber dass die
demokratien sich durchsetzen noch ein
ganz kurzer blick nach vorne sie fliegen
jetzt nach madrid zum nato-gipfel können
wir am ende dieses gipfels erwarten dass
finnland und schweden nato mitglieder
sind bei es sind sie liebt ja ich hoffe
es auf jeden fall
werden sie kennen ja ich hatte
schwierigkeiten
ich bin auf jeden fall zuversichtlich
dass ich das radl ist und die
strategischen vorteile
darin mit uns wie finnland und schweden
mit der nato zu haben sind ja
offensichtlich
wir hatten ja auch gerade darüber
gesprochen wie es ist mit demokratie
die ergebnisse dieser aktiven aggression
durch butter ist dass die nato gestärkt
ist die europa ist gestärkt sieben sind
gestärkt unser
selbstgefühl unsere mission auf der welt
ist auch